en présentant ses excuses lucien
bouchard a évité de jeter le blâme sur
les communautés religieuses
mais il n'a réussi qu'à un disposer
davantage le comité des orphelins de
duplessis qui compte refusé les offres
gouvernementales
les habitants de la petite communauté de
can't get you out jouac dans le grand
nord québécois sont encore sous le choc
au lendemain de l'avalanche qui a
emporté cinq adultes et quatre enfants
et fait 25 blessés
sous le coup de minuit désignés sont
entrés dans une nouvelle ère ils ont
maintenant en main leur avenir
le nunavut est né
[Musique]
oui de réfugiés tchétchènes travers
cette frontière tous les jours il fit
non seulement les bombardements mais
aussi la probabilité que bientôt les
hostilités vont s'intensifier y a pas un
jour de trop pour ceux qui traquent le
fameux bug de l'an 2000 dans les
provinces maritimes on sera les premiers
à subir les problèmes liés au passage à
l'an 2000 et tous les responsables du
blog savent déjà qu'ils vont passer le
réveillon au travail au plus vite mettre
le maire de graver leurs familles
[Musique]
ou par e-mail michael jones
la foule offre une longue ovation pour
dire merci au joueur le plus talentueux
de notre histoire du raccord
[Musique]